hey what's up guys my name is a Chino
and welcome to episode 88 of game
programming so today we're gonna talk
about getting all the sprites that we
made during the after-effects series
series videos into our game this is a
pretty basic thing and it's gonna be
quite short but stay until the end
because at the end I'll be um asking you
guys to do something pretty important
that affects this series so yeah stay
okay so what we've got here is a bunch
of surprise that we made and I don't
think subfloors yeah okay and now what
we want to do is basically arrange them
into a sprite sheet so what we had
before was our spawn level sprite sheet
which was this right we want to kind of
arrange them into the same fashion here
so for that we'll need one - we'll
basically need a 3x3 grid here and of
course three times 32 is 96 so let's
make a new composition that is 96 by 96
and what I'm gonna do here is basically
just pop in our sprites here so we've
got this wall I think the first one is
grass so let's just pop in grass first
there it is make sure that our
anti-aliasing is turned off here and it
was gonna pop it over there into the
corner um it's not is that not 32 by 32
what's going on here
oh it's 16 by 16 that is the size of our
surprise isn't it okay sorry if in that
case it's 48 by 48 not 96 by 96 I
thought we were using them sorry I
thought we were using a 32 size price
okay
so we've got this here now let's grab a
I think our next one here was our
clothes are great our next one was
another grass here but we've a wall and
a floor and then they're not the other
walls so let's grab the wall here and
we'll pop it right over here again turn
the anti-aliasing off if you guys want
me to make this After Effects project as
a download let me know and I'll put that
up on my on my website and like guys
download it because that is absolutely
no problem at all and I'll bundle in all
these images into a zip file as long
long with the actual Ultraflex project
file another thing was the crumply
bricks which i think is called comp one
yep there's very descriptive names here
so we'll just pop that in here and
the wall was the other one so let's grab
our wall which was a sari floor which
was called floor I believe I'm not sure
which one it is
is it the first one the second one
that's first okay it's the first one
because the first one is the one that's
got the second one inside it this is why
you should name things properly by the
way great example so first one it is
again turning anti-hazing off here and
positioning it correctly okay that's
what we've got right now I've got room
for more sprites here so what I might do
is make a new composition that is
sixteen by sixteen will call this dummy
and this will be like the dummy sprite
so what I'll do is I'll quickly make a
new solid and I'll set it to our
favorite pink color which is our
transparency color call that background
and then just around it what I'll do is
I'll probably make a new solid I usually
like a good contrast for this color is
actually seven seven F so this is a deep
of kind of magenta color
and we'll pop that there again that
would be like our border it just looks
nice doesn't it we could of course use
anything for that but that would be like
our dummy so what you'll see here is as
I put that in and turn idealizing off
here and duplicate it four more times or
rather four times yep we can have these
things here so we know where other
sprites should be and also if we get an
air hiss at it don't I'll copy them or
yeah there we go I don't know if we have
an error okay so that's what else brush
it looks like right now
let's hit control s on that and let's
export it so ctrl alt S or you can go
composition say frame as file and we'll
export it as a PNG sequence and of
course we'll pop it into our let's see
yeah
workspace workspace game programming
rain resources textures and in shades
will call it spawn
I'll call it lvl 4 level I just don't
want to override the previous one so hit
random that will render in like one
second let's go into our sprite a sheet
class and we'll just change our sprite
chains have a spawn level here to be lvl
okay and that's it if we run our game
now what we should see is then use
brighter and look at that they actually
look pretty nice I'm not gonna lie there
look pretty nice here and oh I should
have wondered the stuff I was showing
this to a friend of mine and I am I kind
of made the character bleed when he hit
when he hit the wall when he hits the
wall and I forgot to undo that I told
myself like 15 times Jenna I don't
forget but I forgot so I'm sorry um that
shouldn't be there let's let's quickly
I'll show you I'll show you guys what I
mean particle okay
sprite what I what I what I had it is
was um basically whenever the play I
just crashed into the wall let's um I
almost stopped rendering this stupid
spreadsheet but being um where's our
main glass game Java over here we have
the sprite sheet the animated sprite
sheet they were rendering oh we never
finished that did we
we've probably finished that um okay so
let's see so play oh no helmet it was um
screen to render [ __ ] okay now that's
gone
yes I won't have a hit crash into the
wall oh he just bleed all over the place
and I love them just purely fast so that
um that was just me showing the super
answer and I forgot to undo it I always
do this I'm sorry hang on let me quickly
undo that so where are we
sprite let's go back to sprite first of
all and change this color back to that
gray color and let's also go into I
think I changed so many things did I
damage now that would have been in
particle
no hang on I was already in particle
projectile like always can always
confuse projectile on particle with the
projectile we'll change this to 44 and
in I think player I think or is it in
mob I don't freaking know
yeah okay there we go so we should be
back to normal now all right awesome
cool so what we'll cover tomorrow is um
is finishing this this player animation
okay because it kind of looks bad right
now I am actually digging these floors
quite a bit this isn't you look of the
game it kind of looks a lot more
polished I think and the floors do look
pretty awesome actually oh hang on let's
go up and see how crumpled walls here
yeah you see that crumbly look that
looks really cool I think and of course
we'll have to fix up our sprite here as
well as give him a storyline but um that
thing that I was going to ask you guys
to do a lost you has to do that next
episode so make sure you watch the next
episode because um well we haven't
finished the player I thought we did so
yeah and that's pretty much gonna wrap
up this episode if you guys liked it
please hit the like button again if the
video hits 200 likes episode everyday if
the video hits 300 likes to episodes per
day so make sure that you do hit that
like button if you enjoy the video of
course if you didn't and I'm sorry maybe
write a comment thing like channel you
stalk do this do this instead anyway
guys thanks for watching later guys
you